>>> THE REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN OF
MARICOPA COUNTY BOARDS OF
SUPERVISOR, "A GRIFT DISGUISE OF
THE AUDIT."
NOW HE'S SAYING, I AM QUOTING A
FORMER PRESIDENT "THE ENTIRE
DATABASE OF MARICOPA HAS BEEN
DELETED".
ALL OF IT DELETED.
I GUESS YOU COULD NOT CHECK IT
BECAUSE THEY DELETED THE WHOLE
THING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT CONSPIRACY
LEADS TO.
THAT LED TO MY NEXT GUEST WHO
KNOWS WHAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT TO
TWEET, QUOTE, "WOW, THIS IS
UNHINGED, WE CAN'T INDULGE THESE
INSANE LIES ANY LONGER."
STEVEN RICHARD, I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH ERIN.
>> YOU ARE SITTING AT YOUR
COMPUTER AND YOU GOT A COUPLE OF
SCREENS UP LIKE EVERYBODY THESE
DAYS AND YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
VOTER DATABASE AND THE MIDST OF
ALL THIS.
THE ENTIRE DATABASE IN YOUR
COUNTY, THE MOST IMPORTANT
COUNTY BY SIZE AND ARIZONA HAD
BEEN DELETED , ALL CAPS.
WHAT DID YOU DO AT THAT MOMENT?
>> I WACTUALLY GOT THE LETTER T
ME FROM A REPORTER, SHE
BASICALLY SAYS WHAT GIVES AND
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE AND WHY ARE
YOU DELETING FILES.
I WAS SITTING THERE LOOKING AT
OUR VOTER REGISTRATION DATABASE
AND I HAVE THE ELECTION DATABASE
AS WELL AND ON MY COMPUTER.
WHAT CAB WE DO HERE?
THE PENCIL SITTING ON MY DESK IN
FRONT OF ME DOES NOT EXIST.
>> YES, THAT'S WHAT'S SO HARD TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
AND YET PEOPLE STILL BELIEVE IT.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE PENCIL
AND SOMEHOW THEY DON'T BELIEVE
IT IS THERE.
YOU RESPONDED AND YOU TOOK A
STANCE ON THIS.
YOU SAID THE PRESIDENT'S
STATEMENT WAS, QUOTE ON QUOTE,
"UNHINGED."
WHY DID YOU FEEL YOU NEEDED TO
DO THAT AND WHAT GAVE YOU THE
COURAGE TO DO IT?
NOW YOU STUCK YOUR HEAD UP AND
YOU KNOW WHAT IN COMING FEELS
LIKE.
THIS WAS NOT ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IT IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
IN THIS OFFICE, I CAME INTO THIS
OFFICE AND TRYING TO MAKE IT AS
BORING AS POSSIBLE.
I HAVE SITTING ON THE ASIDELINE
AND THIS IS MY FIRST NATIONAL
INTERVIEW.
AT SOME POINT, WE ARE HUMANS,
GOOD PEOPLE WORKING HERE AT
MARICOPA COUNTY.
THAT'S MY TEAM AND MY OFFICE AND
MY FRIENDS.
I WANTED TO SAY SOMETHING AND I
NEVER WOULD HAVE IMAGINED IT
GOTTEN THAT BIG.
>> I KNOW YOU HAVE A MEETING
TODAY HELD BY REPUBLICAN CONTROL
BOARD SUP VERVISORS.
YOU ALREADY HAD TWO AUDITS.
THEY ALL SHOW THE SAME THING
ABOUT WHO WON.
THAT BOARD SENT A 14-PAGE LETTER
TONIGHT OF REFUTING CLAIMS AFTER
CLAIMS AND ACCUSING THE AUDITORS
OF MISCOUNTING THE BALLOTS.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
ALL THIS?
>> JUST INDULGING THIS.
STOP GIVING SPACE FOR LIES.
WE FOUND OUT ABOUT THIS
ACCUSATION THROUGH THE ARIZONA'S
SENATE AUDIT TWITTER ACCOUNT
WHICH IS ANONYMOUSLY RUN, JUST
ACCUSING ME AND MY STAFF OF
UNLAWFULLY COMPLETING EVIDENCE.
THAT'S NOT APPROPRIATE.
I CALLED THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
DID YOU WANT TO ACCUSE ME OF
UNLAWFUL EVIDENCE?
SHE WROTE BACK THAT SHE DID NOT
HAVE CONTROL OVER THESE
ACCOUNTS.
WHAT'S GOING ON AND WHO ARE
THESE PEOPLE DEFAMING US.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE
PROFESSIONALS.
>> THE BOARD NOW WHICH IS THE
THIRD AUDIT AND THIS ONE IS PUT
FORTH BY THE REPUBLICAN STATE'S
SENATE.
YOU ARE SAYING IT NEEDS TO END
FOR THE GOOD OF THE STATE AND
THE COUNTRY.
ANY TIME WE HEARD ABOUT IT OH,
THIS COULD DRAG ON FOR MONTHS.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU ABOUT THAT?
>> THAT'S WHY WE DID THIS.
IT IS EXHAUSTING HAVING TO
RESPOND TO EVERY INSINUATION.
I HAVE NO IDEA HOW LONG THIS
WILL GO ON FOR.
IT WILL POSSIBLY GO INTO 2022
WHERE ANOTHER PIVOTAL COUNTY IN
THE NATIONAL LANDSCAPE BUT THEY
ONLY COMPLETED ONE-FOURTH OF THE
BALLOT S AND THEY HAVE A WHOLE
BUNCH OF OTHER THINGS PLANNED.
THEY ARE ONLY DOING TWO
ELECTIONS ON A BALLOT THAT HAD
OVER 60 ELECTIONS.
HOW THEY CHOSE THAT?
WOULD THEY WANT TO CHOOSE THE
CLOSEST RACE THAT'S ON EVERY
S
SINGLE BALLOT IN MARICOPA
COUNTY.
>> SO YOU ARE SAYING YOURS WHERE
YOU - THEY'RE NOT CONCERNED OF
THE MARGIN OF VICTORY AS
INDICATIVE OF FRAUD.
WHAT'S GIVEN YOU THE COURAGE TO
SPEAK OUT HERE.
THERE WILL BE REPERCUSSIONS OF
YOUR COMING OUT AND SPEAKING THE
FACTS AND SPEAKING WHY YOU THINK
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO THE
COUNTRY.
I KNOW YOU KNOW THAT.
YOU ARE PREPARED FOR THAT.
>> YES, I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES.
THIS HAS BEEN A RUDE AWAKENING
TO WHAT POLITICS HAVE BECOME.
IF I AM NOT PART OF IT FOUR
YEARS FROM NOW, SO BE IT.
I CAN DO OTHER THINGS THAT'LL
MAKE ME HAPPY.
I AM TIRED OF MY PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOOD PEOPLE WHO ARE MY FRIENDS
BEING DEFAMED.
IT IS NOT RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT, STEPHEN, I
APPRECIATE YOUR TI